hi i'm alexis and i'm the senior food
specialist here at tasty today i'm going
to show you how to make my sheet pan
barbecue chicken cornbread sandwiches
it's a mouthful but it's really good
cornbread and barbecue are such a
classic combination and i thought it
might be cool to just put them together
and also take out some of the stress of
having people having to do it by
themselves with the sandwich you get it
all in one
while i was developing this recipe it
was really important to have cornbread
that could stay in a sheet and not
crumble apart some cornbread can be
really dense and crumbly which has its
moments but for this we needed something
a little more malleable
[Music]
i think for me this is a perfect thing
for summer barbecue a party a long
weekend it's really a crowd pleaser and
it's pretty easy to do
[Music]
you want to make sure to grease the
baking sheets and line them with
parchment paper if you don't line them
with parchment paper you're not going to
be able to peel them off in one sheet
and that kind of defeats the whole
purpose you want to make sure to divide
them evenly between the two sheet pans
you don't want one thicker and one
thinner again it's a sandwich you want
them even on both sides the cornbread
bakes really quickly it'll be done in
something like 15 minutes
so while the cornbread's baking you can
move on to the next step which is making
your own barbecue sauce i think when
you're making your own barbecue sauce
the joy is that you can control some
elements like if you want it more spicy
you can add more heat if you want it
sweeter you can add more sugar i just
really like the element of control that
you have when you're making your own
barbecue sauce at home a lot of people
use store bought but it's actually
really easy to make your own sauce it'll
come together in a matter of minutes
so in addition to making our own
barbecue sauce we're also going to make
our own coleslaw the base for the
coleslaw is really easy it's basically
mayonnaise mustard vinegar and some
seasoning
[Music]
so for this coleslaw i'm using a cabbage
and carrots if you wanted to add
something else you totally could
[Music]
you're going to add the shredded chicken
to the barbecue sauce give it a stir
it's that easy
[Music]
when you're ready to assemble you'll
place the shredded chicken all over the
cornbread pop it with coleslaw put the
other cornbread on top of it and then
you can slice it into pieces as big or
small as you want
[Music]
[Music]
you can make them really small and make
them like sliders for a party or you can
make them bigger if you're having like a
family barbecue
[Music]
people love this idea that's kind of
novel of having like a sheet pan
sandwich i think the joy of the sandwich
is having this really saucy chicken this
really flavorful coleslaw and then of
course the cornbread and it's all
together and you can just have it in one
bite truly the best combination i put
chicken inside this sandwich but you
could use pulled pork brisket whatever
your favorite barbecue is let us know in
the comments
we're just to shire i'm using ketchup
worchestershire i can never really say
that
[Music]
you